♪ Yeah, I pledge
allegiance to the flag
♪ Of the United
States of America
♪ Pour me up a Hennessy
and roll me a blunt
♪ So I can smoke one for America
♪ USA, USA, USA
♪ Swag trippin on
a can of something
♪ Soul's trippin
on a can of swag
♪ Swag trippin on
a can of something
♪ Soul's trippin
on a can of swag
♪ Oh say can you see by
the dawn's early light
♪ What so proudly we
hail, after twilight
♪ Those gleaming
♪ Whose bright stripes
and bright stars
♪ Through the perilous fights
♪ Over the ramparts we watched
♪ That were so
gallantly streaming
♪ And the rockets red glare
♪ The bombs bursting in air
♪ Gave truth to the night
♪ That our flag was still there
♪ Where it at, where it at
♪ There it at, there it at
♪ Okay? Oh say, that star
spangled banner yet wave
♪ Over the land of the free
and the home of the brave
♪ Oh say, oh say
♪ Over the land of the free
♪ And the home of the brave
♪ I pledge allegiance
to the flag
to the swag
♪ I pledge allegiance
to the streets
to the flag
♪ Obama, Obama
♪ Trapped out
♪ Obama Obama
♪ Obama, Obama
♪ Trapped out in the trap house
♪ Obama Obama
♪ Trapped out
♪ Over the land of the free
♪ And the home of the brave
♪ America, America,
♪ America, where we get paid
♪ America, home of the brave
♪ America built by the slaves
♪ You know where bus everyday
♪ You know we paying that money
♪ America, America's
national anthem
♪ We gettin that money
(crowd cheers)
- Run it back!
I'm just kidding,
I'm just kidding.
We got more show.
Now if we've learned anything
from Bill Maher this month
it's that a slip up on
national TV can ruin your life.
So this is "Ruin Your Life"
Simple game
- Alright, okay.
- Four questions
(bell)
All you got to do is
answer the questions
and you get the prize.
- What's the prize?
- First question,
(bell)
what's your name?
- Gareth.
- Killian.
- What's your name?
- Sammy.
- How old are you?
- 23.
- 21.
- 22
- 32.
- How old are you?
- 29.
- 32.
- It don't matter.
- Where do you work at?
(bell)
- I'm in college.
- What do you do for a living?
- Oh, nothing.
- Last question
(bell)
- Alright.
- Will you say the "n" word?
- Get the (bleep) out of here.
- For a bead will
you say the "n" word?
- (bleep)
(long buzzer)
- That happened.
You've been the first contestant
on "Ruin Your Life!"
She said it, not me.
For two beads each, will
you two look at the camera
and say the "n" word?
- The "n" word?
- The "n" word.
- No, that's not right.
- You said, "no
that's not right?"
What about you?
- No, it's not right.
- That's correct!
The "n" word was no!
Why can't we all be
like Ireland goddamnit?
Why can't we all
be like Ireland?
It's cracked, the session's lit
and nobody's saying nigger.
(long buzzer)
- It's not right.
(crowd cheers)
- It's not right,
you heard Killian!
Come on now you know
if you're allowed
to say it or not.
The permission slip
is in your soul
and in your pigmentation.